face aux menaces d'invasion russe en
ukraine l'otan l'organisation du traité
de l'atlantique nord stone son grand
retour les états unis envoient des
troupes supplémentaires en europe de
l'est et réaffirment leur détermination
à défendre leurs alliés contre toute
agression
il est important que nous envoyons un
message fort à monsieur politisée que
l'otan compte pour les états unis elle
compte pour nos alliés nous avons d
engagement inébranlable une attaque
contre l'un d'entre eux est une attaque
contre tous
la crise ukrainienne à renforcer la
cohésion d'une organisation qui avait
traversé ces dernières années une
période difficile dans un entretien
donné asie économistes en 2019 le
président emmanuel macron jugé
l'alliance en état de mort cérébrale une
déclaration tonitruante pour déplorer
notamment le manque de coordination
entre les états unis et leurs alliés sur
le dossier syrien des questions que j'ai
posées sont des questions ouvertes que
nous n'avons pas résolu
la paix en europe le poste effet ni
la relation avec la russie le sujet de
la turquie je me félicite que chacun
maintenant considère que la priorité
plutôt de réfléchir à nos finalité et
nos objectifs stratégiques donald trump
avait lui jugé l'alliance obsolète
lorsqu'il était candidat avant de
revenir sur ses propos une fois
président mais il a ensuite multiplié
les attaques contre ses alliés accusés
de ne pas contribuer rasées au
financement de l'alliance
les etats-unis paient actuellement
beaucoup plus que tout autre pays et ce
n'est pas juste pour les états unis où
le contribuable américain nous sommes
toujours derrière l'otan mais nous
voulons être traités équitablement
avec la situation en ukraine l'alliance
atlantique sans pose de nouveau comme
l'acteur incontournable de la sécurité
européenne